[Music]
is this one of the first nights out I
mean that little one is new yeah yeah we
had a couple nights but we just don't
want to be away from her she's just like
I thought you wrote like the sweetest
Instagram is it hard to leave her
because she's just I mean you've got to
just be so in love yeah I mean like it's
like a piece of your body's away from
you it's true the fact that you guys
took the time is that a really
meaningful night for you yeah absolutely
I mean one of the greatest men I've ever
met in my entire life my father-in-law
her father was diagnosed with MS 13
years ago pretty much to the day today
and so anytime that there's a light
shined on this terrible disease creating
this sense of community it's a beautiful
thing to talk about just having a baby
like make you fall even more in love
with each other because you guys already
feel like soulmates
oh my gosh it's a I didn't think you
can't imagine that you could love each
other even deeper than you already do
but I think it's just so cool you know
we weren't blood related before but now
there's this human that we're both
related to and it just like makes us
family in a new way
amazing was Bryan Cranston met this baby
yes of course of course yeah
he's madly in love with her both him and
his wonderful wife Robin
you look gorgeous girl she pushed the
baby out ten weeks ago and it's amazing
[Music]